We are now ready to present the algorithm
for solving the decoding problem that
was developed by Andrew Viterbi for decoding.
To implement the dynamic programming for
decoding problem,
we introduce the variable score_(k,i), which
corresponds to the maximum product weight
among all paths from source to node_(k,i),
or the node corresponding to state k and
located in the ith column of the graph.
Let's consider all predecessors of this
node corresponding to all possible states.
And obviously, the score at the node_(k,i)
equals the maximums through all
possible states l of scores
in the previous column multiplied
by the weight of the edge
from the node in the previous column,
node l, to the node k in the column i,
which is, in other words,
the maximum through all state
scores in the previous column
multiplied by the weight of
the edge (l,k,i-1).
So the recurrence for
Viterbi Algorithm with be
score_(k,i) equals the maximum through all states:
score_(l,i-1) * weight_(l,k,i-1).
The initialization, of course,
is score_source = 1.
And the maximum product weight
over all paths from source to sink
is computed at the node sink, which
the score of sink will be the maximum
through all states of the scores
in the last column of the Manhattan.
Now, lets estimate the running
time of the Viterbi Algorithm
in the case when HMM has
forbidden transition.
Forbidden transition means
that the probability of switching
for a given pair of states is zero.
For example, in this HMM diagram,
there are four states,
but as you see,
there are no edges connecting some states.
They correspond to forbidden
transitions in the HMM.
You notice that the number of edges in
this case in the Viterbi's Manhattan is smaller
than for the case of the full HMM diagram,
when all transitions are allowed.
And in this case, the running time is,
of course, number of edges
in the HMM diagram multiplied by
the number of emitted symbols n.
You, of course,
notice that, if in the past we were
maximizing the sum of weights of
edges in the paths in the graph,
now we maximize the product of edges for
the paths in the graph.
And when we maximize the product,
there is a danger of overflow.
Therefore, bioinformaticians prefer
to work with logarithms of scores.
So if you transform the currency for
the score_(k,i) by taking its logarithm,
then the currency corresponding
to the product of weights
is transformed into the currency
corresponding to the sum of weights,
and this transformation substitutes
weight of edges by their logarithms
and transforms product of weights
into the familiar sum of weights,
so there is no difference between
computing an optimal solution
in the decoding problem and
the traditional longest path in the graph,
something that we studied before.
Note that we have already learned
how to compute the probability
of the hidden path pi, and
it turned out to be easy.
It amounted simply to multiplication
of transition probability,
and our intuition tells us that it will probably
be equally easy to compute the probability
of the emitted sequence x. Let's see
whether our intuition is correct.
So, when we compute Pr(pi),
it is simply multiplication of transition
probabilities, but when we compute Pr(x),
it's the sum
through all possible paths pi
of Pr(x,pi),
and it is not clear how
to compute this sum.
Note that Pr(x) is the sum through
all possible hidden paths pi
of the product weight of pi.
And compared with the score at sink
in our Viterbi Manhattan,
which is the maximum through all possible
paths pi of the product weight of pi.
These two expressions
look extremely similar.
Lets try to see whether we can
explore this similarity to come up
with an algorithm for computing
the probability of the emitted sequence x.
So to find out what is the most
likely outcome of an HMM,
we must first need to solve the following
outcome likelihood problem:
Find the probability that
an HMM emits a given string.
The input is a string x emitted, by an HMM,
and the output is the probability
that the HMM emits this string.
And since you already saw the similarity
between computing probability of x and
the Viterbi algorithm, let's try to
figure out whether we can solve
the outcome likelihood problem by changing
a single symbol in the Viterbi recurrence.
So, let's try to modify
the Viterbi algorithm and
introduce a variable forward_(k,i),
which is the total product weight
of all paths to the node (k,i).
Here are all predecessor of node k,
and therefore,
forward_(k,i) is equal to the sum through all
possible states of the values
forward_(l,i-1) in the previous column
multiplied by the weight of the edge
from the previous column to node k,
which is simply the sum
through all state l:
forward_(l,i-1) * weight_(l,k,i-1).
And, the only difference between this
recurrence for forward_(k,i) and score_(k,i)
is the change of maximum into sum.
Now, that's all interesting,
but you may have the question:
What does it all have to do with
biological applications?
And, in the next section,
we will start looking
at the application of HMMs
to finding protein families.